IS THAT?
>> Tucker: SOUNDS LIKE A GOOD
NIGHT FOR ME.
>> Sean: THANK YOU, WELCOME TO
"HANNITY," TONIGHT THIS IS THE
REAL DEAL, INCHING CLOSER AND
CLOSER TO TRUTH AND JUSTICE, AND
HOLDING THOSE THAT ABUSE POWER
ACCOUNTABLE.
FOR TWO YEARS ON THIS PROGRAM,
WE HAVE WATCHED A POLITICAL
PERSECUTION, ALL BASED ON LIES
AND A HOAX DRIVEN BY ANTI-TRUMP
HATRED, THAT LITERALLY WRECKS OF
THE VERY FABRIC OF OUR SOCIETY.
WE HAVE MASSIVE DEVELOPMENTS
TONIGHT ON MANY FRONTS, THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL WILLIAM BARR
WENT BEFORE THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE TODAY
AND THE BOOMERANG THAT I HAVE
BEEN TELLING YOU ABOUT IS
EMOTION.
HEADED RIGHT BACK IN THE
DIRECTION THAT I TOLD YOU IT
WOULD HEAD.
AND WE HAVE A BRAND-NEW JUST
RELEASED TODAY CLOSED-DOOR
TESTIMONY FROM THE GENERAL
COUNSEL THE FBI UNDER COMEY.
FULL OF MASSIVE EXAMPLES OF
UPPER ECHELON FBI DOJ ABUSE OF
POWER.
AND JUST BREAKING MOMENTS AGO,
MULTIPLE OUTLETS INCLUDING
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL"
REPORTING GREG CRAIG, THE
WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL FOR
BARACK OBAMA EXPECTS TO BE
INDICTED OVER HIS WORK IN
UKRAINE, WE WILL HAVE MORE ON
THAT IN A MOMENT.
ALSO WE BEGIN WITH THE "HANNITY
TRUTH WATCH" WITH A QUESTION.
HOW DID ALL OF THIS HAPPEN?
HOW DID IT BEGIN?
WE HAVE TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
THIS OR WE WILL NOT HAVE EQUAL
JUSTICE AND EQUAL APPLICATION OF
OUR LAWS.
FUTURE ELECTIONS, AND YES,
POTENTIAL PRESIDENTIAL
DEEP STATE WHO WILL OCCUR.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL DELIVERED A
BOMBSHELL ARGUMENT DURING HIS
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE,
EXACTLY WHAT WE HAVE BEEN
TELLING YOU, OVER TWO YEARS IS
TRUE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> YES, I THINK THAT'S FINE DID
OCCUR.
>> WELL, LET ME --
>> THE QUESTION IS WHETHER IT
WAS PREDICATED, ADEQUATELY
PREDICATED PARADE I'M NOT
SUGGESTING THAT IT WASN'T
ADEQUATELY PREDICATED.
BUT I NEED TO EXPLORE THAT.
IT IS MY OBLIGATION, CONGRESS
IT'S USUALLY VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES STAYING
IN THE PROPER LANE, AND I WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT HAPPEN.
WE HAVE A LOT OF RULES ABOUT
THAT.
AND, A LOT OF SAY AND I HAVE
SAID, I AM REVIEWING THIS, I AM,
I HAVE NOT SET UP A TEAM YET,
BUT I DO HAVE, I HAVE IN MIND
HAVING SOME COLLEAGUES PULL THIS
INFORMATION TOGETHER AND LETTING
ME KNOW WHETHER THERE ARE SOME
AREAS THAT SHOULD BE LOOKED AT.
>> Sean: THIS IS DOWNRIGHT
SCARY, EVERY SINGLE AMERICAN,
NOT POLITICAL, NOT DEMOCRAT,
REPUBLICAN, BLUE, RED, IT IS NOT
ABOUT POLITICS.
WE GAVE OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIALS ARE INTELLIGENCE
OFFICIALS THE MOST POWERFUL
TOOLS OF INTELLIGENCE, THEY ARE
NEVER TO BE WEAPONIZED AGAINST
WE, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, MUCH
LESS A POLITICAL CAMPAIGN AT THE
HEIGHT OF AN ELECTION OR TO UNDO
AN ELECTION, WHERE ARE ALL OF
THE SEVERAL LIBERTARIANS ON THE
LEFT?
WHERE THE INVESTIGATIONS.
YOU HAVE SCHUMER, BLUMENTHAL,
FREAKING OUT TONIGHT, CALLING
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL, CALLING ON
HIM TO RETRACT HIS TRUTH ROLL
REMARKS.
THEY CANNOT HANDLE THE TRUTH.
SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI SAID THAT
WILLIAM BARR WAS OFF THE RAILS.
IMAGINE, NANCY PELOSI SAID THAT
ABOUT SOMEBODY ELSE.
FUNNY.
>> LET ME JUST SAY HOW VERY,
VERY DISMAYING AND DISAPPOINTING
THAT THE CHIEF LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER OF OUR COUNTRY IS GOING
OFF THE RAILS.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA, NOT
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
I'VE DONE OF DONALD TRUMP.
>> Sean: THEY DO NOT WANT HIM
TO PROVIDE THE PROPER OVERSIGHT
AND THE LAW, THEY WHO ADVANCE
THE TRUMP WITCH HUNT, THEY'VE
WHO LIVE FOR YEARS ARE EXPOSED
AS A FRAUDS THAT THEY ARE, THEY
DO NOT WANT THE TRUTH.
TO THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA IS
TRYING THEIR VERY BEST TO PLAY
DOWN ALL OF THE BOMBSHELLS THAT
WE HAVE TONIGHT.
"WASHINGTON POST," FOR
CONSERVATIVE WRITER JENNIFER
RUBIN CALLING ON WILLIAM BARR TO
BE IMPEACHED, FAR LEFT
CONSPIRACY SYCOPHANTS AT MSNBC,
TINFOIL HAT CONSPIRACY MSNBC,
FAKE NEWS CNN, ALSO TRASHING THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
GEE, AND ROD ROSENSTEIN, OR
MUELLER, TAKE A LOOK.
>> I SPY AND ATTORNEY GENERAL
GIVING CREDENCE TO CONSPIRACY
THEORIES.
>> IT FEELS LIKE THAT BASICALLY
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL GAS LET THE
COUNTRY.
>> BILL BARR, ONE OF THE MOST
RESPECTED LAWYERS, IT TWO TIME
ATTORNEY GENERAL TURNING IN HIS
TORTOISESHELL GLASSES FOR A
TINFOIL HAT.
>> I WILL BE AN ENGINE FOR THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
I'M NOT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL FOR
THE COUNTRY.
>> THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE
UNITED STATES AND A DOG WHISTLE
TO THE SEAN HANNITY IS A BIG
DEAL.
>> HE IS A FLUNKY FOR
DONALD TRUMP.
HE IS NOT AN INDEPENDENT
THINKER.
HE SOUNDS GOOD, HE SEEMS
SINCERE.
BUT IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT HE DOES,
NOT WHAT HE SAYS, YOU SEE THE
ACTIONS OF A HATCHET MAN COMING
OUT IT IS REALLY DISTURBING.
>> Sean: CONSPIRACY THEORIST
FOR TWO AND A HALF YEARS LYING,
THE VERY PEOPLE THAT LIVE FOR
TWO AND A HALF YEARS.
THEY DON'T WANT A TINFOIL HAT
CONSPIRACY THEORIES, THE LIES
EXPOSED.
THEY HAVE BEEN PUSHING IT EVERY
SECOND, EVERY HOUR, EVERY DAY.
INCLUDING THEIR COVERAGE OF THIS
VERY TOPIC, JUST A FEW MONTHS
AGO.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
>> WHAT WE HAVE SEEN AND HEARD
FROM THE PRESIDENT IN THE PAST
FIVE DAYS MAY BE THE BIGGEST LIE
OF ALL.
REPEATEDLY, AND WITH NO FACTS TO
BACK HIM UP, MAKING THE
OUTRAGEOUS CLAIM THAT THE
SO-CALLED "DEEP STATE" SPIED ON
HIS CAMPAIGN.
>> TO CALL IT A CONSPIRACY
THEORY IS TO GIVE THEM TOO MUCH
CREDIT.
>> THE NOTION THAT THE FBI
IMPLANTED, PLANTED SOMEONE
INSIDE THE CAMPAIGN TO SPY ON
THE CAMPAIGN IS JUST NOT TRUE.
>> THE UNPROVEN NARRATIVE OF A
SPY BEING PLACED INSIDE HIS
CAMPAIGN.
>> DID THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY SPY ON PRESIDENT TRUMP
IN THE CAMPAIGN?
>> NO, WE DID NOT.
>> Sean: THEY DID AND THEY
HAVE BEEN LYING FOR TWO AND A
HALF YEARS.
AND LYING TO YOU, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS RIGHT ALL
ALONG.
WE WERE RIGHT ALL ALONG.
THEY HAVE NO CHARACTER, NO
ETHICS, NO INTEGRITY.
THEY SHOULD BE APOLOGIZING,
RETRACTING, CORRECTING ALL OF
THE DAMAGE THAT THEY HAVE DONE.
THEY JUST DOUBLE DOWN ON LINE.
IN THE MEDIA, THE DEMOCRATS,
THEY ARE SO BLINDED BY THIS
HATE, THIS RAGE.
THE AIR AND CAPABLE OF SEEING
THE STONE COLD TRUTH RIGHT
BEFORE THEIR EYES.
LET'S LOOK AT THIS, JULY 2016,
WE KNOW THAT THE FBI OPENED UP A
COUNTER COUNTER INTELLIGENCE AS
ITS INVESTIGATION INTO THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN AIDE GEORGE
PAPADOPOULOS AFTER HE SPOKE WITH
AN INFORMANT, MAYBE EVEN BEFORE
THIS, WE KNOW IN THE SAME MONTH,
THE FBI ATTEMPTED TO WIRETAP
CARTER PAGE FOR NO GOOD REASON.
WE KNOW THAT IN JULY 2016, TOP
OBAMA OFFICIALS INCLUDING SUSAN
RICE, THE YEAR 2016, THEY RAMPED
UP THEIR OWN MASKING EFFORTS A
WHOPPING 350%.
FINAL YEAR, THE ELECTION YEAR
COMING IN OCTOBER 2016, THE FBI
BEGAN SUCCESSFULLY SPYING ON
CARTER PAGE AFTER GETTING THAT
FISA WARRANT BY COMMITTING A
FRAUD ON MULTIPLE LEVELS TOWED
THE FISA COURT.
USING CLINTON'S SPOT AND PAY FOR
THE RUSSIAN LIES.
THEY NEVER TOLD THE JUDGE IS
THAT.
THE BULK OF INFORMATION WERE
UNVERIFIED, UNCOOPERATED,
INFORMATION PAID FOR BY HILLARY.
AND GUESS WHAT, THEY DENIED AN
AMERICAN CITIZEN HIS
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS.
AND THEY GOT THEIR BACK DOOR
RIGHT INTO THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
THROUGH CARTER PAGE.
AND IN DECEMBER THE
15TH OF 2016.
WE KNOW THAT THE OBAMA
OFFICIALS, OH, THEY JUST
INCIDENTALLY SPIED ON TRUMP
OFFICIALS AFTER SUSAN RICE,
WELL, SHE REPORTEDLY UNMASKED
THE NAMES OF STEVE BANNON, JARED
KUSHNER, LIEUTENANT GENERAL 33
YEAR VETERAN MICHAEL FLYNN.
YES, THERE WAS FINE.
AS WE HAVE REPORTED, MORE
RIGHTLY SO MANY, MANY TIMES.
SADLY, THAT IS ONLY ONE SMALL
PART OF THIS ABUSE OF POWER AND
CORRUPTION.
THROUGHOUT THE NIGHT WE WILL
SHOW YOU IN FULL TIMELINE.
WE HAVE REPORTED EVERYTHING.
GUESS WHAT, AFTER MONTHS AND
MONTHS OF WAITING.
THE TRUTH AND JUSTICE AND FACTS
IN SPITE OF ALL OF THEM ARE NOW
BECOMING CASCADING DOWN AND WILL
DROWN THE PROPER PEOPLE.
THE HORWITZ REPORT, THE COOPER
REPORT, THE CLOSED-DOOR
TESTIMONY, WE WILL GET THOSE
PHIS APPLICATIONS, THE GANG OF
EIGHT MATERIALS, THE THREE OH
TWOS, WE ARE WAITING ON A
FLORIDA COURT TO RELEASE
INFORMATION ON CHRISTOPHER
STEELE THAT SHOULD BE VERY
REVEALING AND ENLIGHTENING.
AND IN ANSWER TO THIS IMPORTANT
QUESTION, WATCH.
>> WOULD IT BE ODD THAT THE
CANDIDATE WAS NEVER REALLY
BRIEFED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE THAT YOUR CAMPAIGN MAY
BE TARGETED BY A FOREIGN ENTITY?
>> THAT IS ONE OF THE QUESTIONS
THAT I HAVE AS I FEEL NORMALLY
AT THE CAMPAIGN WOULD HAVE BEEN
ADVISED OF THIS.
>> OKAY COMING AND CAN YOU THINK
OF A GOOD REASON RIGHT NOW WHY
THEY WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN?
>> I AM INTERESTED IN GETTING
THAT ANSWER.
THEY HAD TWO FORMER U.S.
ATTORNEY IS IN CHRIS CHRISTIE
AND RUDY GIULIANI INVOLVED IN
THE CAMPAIGN, AND I DO NOT
UNDERSTAND WHY THE CAMPAIGN WAS
NOT ADVISED.
>> Sean: CLEARLY THERE WAS
EXTREME CORRUPTION BY A POWERFUL
FEW AT THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF OUR
GOVERNMENT.
THE EVIDENCE OF THIS IS RIDDLED
THROUGHOUT THE NOW PUBLIC
TRANSCRIPT OF THE BIGGER
TESTIMONY.
TODAY CONGRESSMAN DOUG COLLINS
RELEASED A SECOND DAY OF
CLOSED-DOOR TESTIMONY FROM THE
FBI'S FORMER TOP LOWER YOUR.
TONIGHT WE ARE LEARNING VERY
REVEALING BRAND-NEW BOMBSHELLS.
INCLUDING THAT THE BAKER, THE
DOJ WAS HAVING DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
APPOINTING AN INDEPENDENT
COUNSEL TO INVESTIGATE THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN LONG BEFORE COMEY WAS
FIRED.
"I DON'T EVEN REMEMBER WHO SAID
IT QUITE HONESTLY, BUT I AM
TELLING YOU THAT THE TOPIC DID
COME UP BEFORE THE FIRING."
NOW WAIT, WE ARE TOLD THAT THAT
EIGHT DAYS IN MAY AFTER COMEY
WAS FIRED, THAT'S WHAT TRIGGERED
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL.
IT WAS IN THE WORKS ALL ALONG,
BECAUSE COMEY, STRZOK, PAGE, AND
ALL OF THE OFFICIALS THAT
THOUGHT THAT HILLARY SHOULD WIN
100000000-0, AND WE ARE SMELLY
WALMART PEOPLE THAT WILL VOTE
FOR TOM, THEY HAD AN INSURANCE
POLICY, IN FACT, BAKER ALLEGING
THAT McCABE, PAGE, ROD
ROSENSTEIN WERE DISCUSSING
UNDOING AN ELECTION BY USING
THE 25TH AMENDMENT.
EVEN ALLEGEDLY BREAKING THAT
THEY HAD TWO ADMINISTRATION
CABINET MEMBERS ON BOARD WITH
THE SCHEME, THE PLOT, THE COUP.
NO JOKING MATTER.
BAKER TESTIFIED "I TOOK IT
SERIOUSLY, BECAUSE MY ASSESSMENT
WAS THAT THEY TOOK IT
SERIOUSLY."
BAKER ALSO REVEALING THAT ROD
ROSENSTEIN OFFERED TO WEAR THAT
WIRE AND SPY ON THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES WITHOUT CAUSE,
AND THAT NO ONE ALERTED THE
PRESIDENT OR ANYONE ELSE ABOUT
THIS ILLEGAL PLOT.
AND KEEP IN MIND, WHILE
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS AT HIS
INAUGURATION, THE PAID FOR DIRTY
DOSSIER BY REPORTER DAVID CORN,
AND A LAWYER ASSOCIATED WITH THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN.
NOW THE CONTENTS OF THE DOSSIER
WERE BEING PASSED AROUND AT THE
HIGHEST LEVELS OF THE DOJ, FBI,
INTEL COMMITTEE, AROUND THE SAME
TIME THAT CLINTON WAS CLEARED OF
ALL CHARGES.
BAKER TESTIFIED THAT HE THOUGHT
HILLARY CLINTON SHOULD HAVE BEEN
INDICTED.
HE HAS THE TOP LAWYER UNDER
COMEY.
"I HAD THAT BELIEF INITIALLY
AFTER REVIEWING A LARGE BINDER
OF HER EMAILS THAT HAD
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION IN THEM.
THAT IS A VIOLATION, 18 USC,
793, THAT IS THE ESPIONAGE ACT.
BAKER SAID THAT HE WAS PERSUADED
OUT OF IT BY HIS COLLEAGUES.
THEY WENT TO THE CLINTON MATTER
SWEPT UNDER THE RUG, EVEN PAGE
AND STRZOK SAID THAT THE FIX WAS
IN.
ALL OF THAT DECISIONS ARE MADE
BY LORETTA LYNCH AND THE
DEMOCRATS AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
NOW LOOK AT THE NEW TIMELINE,
HOW DID WE GET TO THIS POINT?
LET'S START JULY 10, 2015, THE
FBI OPENED A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION, CODE NAME MIDYEAR
EXAM INTO HILLARY CLINTON'S
HANDLING OF CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION ON THAT PRIVATE
SERVER.
SEPTEMBER 2015, OBAMA'S AG,
LAREDO LYNCH ASKED THE FBI
DIRECTOR COMEY TO REFER TO THE
INVESTIGATION NOT AS AN
INVESTIGATION, BUT A MATTER.
ON MARCH 4TH, 2016, TOP FBI
OFFICIALS STRZOK AND PAIGE ARE
TEXTING ABOUT THEIR UTTER
CONTEMPT FOR DONALD TRUMP, ONE
TIME CALLING HIM AN 88.
A SAYING THAT CLINTON SHOULD
WIN.
100000000-0.
AND THAT WE ARE SMELLY WALMART
VOTERS OF TRUMP.
AND IN MARCH 2ND, MAY 2ND RATHER
OF 2016, COMEY, STRZOK DRAFTING
A LETTER EXONERATING HILLARY,
CHANGING THE LANGUAGE FROM GROSS
NEGLIGENCE TO EXTREME
CARELESSNESS, WHAT IT -- WHICH
IS A IS NOT BEFORE THEY
INVESTIGATED HILLARY COMING IN
ON JUNE 27, 2016, THAT'S WHEN
LYNCH MET BILL CLINTON IN A
SECRET MEETING AT A PRIVATE
PLANE ON A TARMAC IN PHOENIX.
JULY 22ND, 2016, 2 MONTHS AFTER
THE BEGINNING OF THE
EXONERATION.
OTHER KEY WITNESSES,
HILLARY CLINTON FINALLY
INTERVIEWED BY PETER STRZOK WHO
HATES TRUMP, AND OTHER FBI
AGENTS.
IN JULY 5TH, COMEY EXONERATES
CLINTON.
IN THE VERY SAME MONTH.
THEN THE FBI OPENS A
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION INTO TRUMP-RUSSIA
COLLUSION.
THAT ONE IS CALLED CROSS FIRE
HURRICANE.
IN THE VERY SAME MONTH, THE
ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR BRUCE OHR
MEETS WITH CHRISTOPHER STEELE ON
MULTIPLE OCCASIONS, BUT HIS WIFE
NELLIE WORKS WITH STEELE, AND
SHARES THE DIRTY RUSSIAN DOSSIER
WITH McCABE, STRZOK, PAGE,
EVEN ANDREW WEISSMANN AND
OTHERS.
AND WARNS THEM THAT THE DOSSIERI
AND WARNS THEM THAT THE DOSSIERS
CAMPAIGN OP RESEARCH.
IT IS NOT VERIFIED, HILLARY PAID
FOR IT AND STEELE HATE TRUMP.
FBI OPERATIVES MEET WITH THE
TRUMP ADVISORS, PAIGE, GEORGE
PAPADOPOULOS SECRETLY GATHERING
INFORMATION FOR THE FBI.
THEN ON AUGUST 15TH, AGAIN,
2016, BEFORE THE ELECTION,
STRZOK TAX LISA PAGE ABOUT A
SCENARIO WHERE PRESIDENT TRUMP
GETS ELECTED, WE CANNOT TAKE
THAT RISK.
AND THEY SPEAK OF NEEDING THE
INSURANCE POLICY.
SEPTEMBER 2ND, 2016, PAGE AND
STRZOK TEXT THAT PRESIDENT OBAMA
WANTS TO KNOW EVERYTHING WE ARE
DOING.
OCTOBER 22ND, 2016, THAT'S WHEN
THE FBI OBTAINED THE FISA
WARRANT TO SURVEILLED CARTER
PAGE, BOTH OF THE APPLICATION
REVILING THE LEAN BACK REVEALING
STEELE'S DOSSIER WITH LIES PAID
BY HILLARY, WOW, A WHOLE ENTRY
INTO THE ENTIRE WORLD OF
DONALD TRUMP AND HIS CAMPAIGN.
ON OCTOBER 1ST, 2016, THE FBI
FIRES CHRISTOPHER STEELE FOR
LYING AND LEAKING, DECEMBER
15TH, PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
PRESIDENT-ELECT, OBAMA INTEL
OFFICIALS ACCIDENTALLY "SPY ON T
OFFICIALS ACCIDENTALLY "SPY ON U
OFFICIALS ACCIDENTALLY "SPY ON P
OFFICIALS" OBAMA NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISER SUSAN ROSS
IMPORTING THE NAMES OF BANNON,
KUSHNER, AND GENERAL FLYNN.
2017, COMEY BRIEFING THE
PRESIDENT AT THE DOCUMENTS WERE
SALACIOUS AND UNVERIFIED, BUT IN
OCTOBER HE SIGNED THE FIRST FISA
WARRANT.
MAY 9TH, 2017, THE PRESIDENT
FIRED FBI DIRECTOR COMEY MAKING
TRUMP HAIDER ANDREW McCABE THE
ACTING FBI DIRECTOR.
HE IS FRIENDS WITH PAGE AND
STRZOK.
MAY 17, APPOINTING ROBERT
MUELLER SPECIAL COUNSEL, AND
IMMEDIATELY HIRES STRZOK,
WISEMAN, JEANNIE RAY, AND ANDREW
WEISSMANN WAS AT THE VICTORY
PARTY, THE ATTORNEY FOR THE
CLINTON FOUNDATIONS, AND ALL
DEMOCRATS AND BUILDERS TO LEAD
THE INVESTIGATION.
THE MAJORITY OF THE STAFF BIG
TIME DEMOCRATIC DONORS, ZERO
REPUBLICANS HIRED.
JUNE 8TH, 2017, FORMER FBI
DIRECTOR COMEY ENGINEERED A LEAK
OF HIS OWN, MEMO TO
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," SPURRING
THE APPOINTMENT OF THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
FLASH FORWARD, MARCH 2ND, THIS
YEAR.
NEARLY TWO YEARS, $30 MILLION
LATER, NO COLLUSION, NO
OBSTRUCTION, NOTHING.
THE EVIDENCE IS CLEAR.
THE PRESIDENT WAS SET UP BY A
POWERFUL GROUP OF UNELECTED
INDIVIDUALS DESPERATE TO STOP